foreign
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor hello listening friends would
you like to hear an amazing fact
in 1954 a little four-year-old girl
Marina Chapman was abducted from her
home in a remote Mountain Village in
South America
evidently something went wrong with the
kidnapping plans and her captors
abandoned her deep in the Colombian
jungle
though often tormented by insects and
loneliness Marina miraculously survived
five years with the help of a troop of
capuchin monkeys
there's plenty of water in the jungle
and the monkeys would often leave her
scraps of fruit and seeds until she
learned to find it for herself
she eventually learned to climb trees
and even catch small birds with her bare
hands
when two Hunters found her five years
later she'd forgotten any human language
and lost all inhibition not remembering
her birth name she never found her
family
Marina was later adopted and became
re-civilized moved to the UK where she
married and had a family a few years ago
her story was produced in a book called
The girl with a known name can you
imagine that Pastor Ross living out
there in the jungle thinking you're an
animal and then discovering you're a
human and it's like you find out you're
a different creature that's right yeah
just sort of being raised by the monkeys
at least following their example and
finding what food you could and then wow
there's people like me out there yeah
there's not enough time to tell the
whole story but she said she spent
enough time where she understood the
simple language of the monkeys I mean
you know they didn't speak but they had
different signals for different things
and she she could recognize them and
when people doubted her story
some of the zoologists would listen to
her descriptions of the capuchin monkeys
and how they communicate and they said
she sounds like she lived with monkeys
she knew a lot about them and anyway
she's still alive today but it's a
fascinating story and it makes me think
about uh finding out you're a different
creature reminds me of that verse now
King James says a little differently
there in second Corinthians 5 17 If any
man is in Christ he is a new creature I
think other versions say a new creation
old things are passed away behold all
things are become new and boy she had a
whole new life when she went from the
jungle to being adopted by a family and
going from the jungle to living in
England let me talk about a radical
transformation
and of course you know you the point you
bring out there if we want to go from
living on this Earth filled with sun and
sorrow suffering and death to the new
Earth where there is peace and joy and
eternal life it requires a radical
change Jesus said to Nicodemus you must
be born again or you cannot even see the
sea the kingdom of heaven so our free
gift talks about that experience of
being born again it's called life in the
spirit and this is free we'll send it to
those who are listening if you're in
North America just call our number it's
800-835-6747 you can ask for the free
gift it's called life in the spirit you
can also dial pound 250 on your
smartphone say Bible answers live and
then also ask for the book life in the
spirit if you're outside of North
America and of course Pastor Doug we
have many people who are listening
around the world just go to the website
just
amazingfacts.org we have a free library
and you'll be able to read the book
there as well
well before we go to the phone lines as
we always do we like to start the
program with prayer so let's do that now
dear father we thank you for this time
that we have to be able to open up your
word and study and father it is I desire
that because of the program that's
happening this evening that lives will
be transformed that people might be born
again and so Lord we ask for your spirit
to guide in these
um in the time together and the
questions and in the answers and we ask
this in Jesus name amen amen our first
caller this evening is Dan listening in
Colorado Dan you're on Bible answers
live welcome
hey pastors good evening to you evening
as such thoughts as we're maybe driving
a car and we're tempted to drive over
this motorcycle
officer or if we're going to run our car
off of a bridge or so does this come
from an evil heart or the wicked one I
get these thoughts all the time of
course I do not act on them do they show
my evil heart
well I I do think that uh you know all
of us are Fallen also keep in mind our
minds are kind of creative computers and
I'd be embarrassed for anybody to see
all the crazy thoughts that goes through
my mind you know most of them we know
how to subdue
and we put them out of our minds but
because God gave us curiosity and he
gave us imagination there's all kinds of
things that'll swirl around in your
brain if there's any kind of thought
that is evil or you're gonna you know
harm somebody or it's sinful or impure
when we recognize those thoughts are
coming then we need to put them out some
of it is the Temptation Of The Devil
some of it James says we're we're drawn
away by our own evil lusts and so in the
same way the devil was a free moral
agent that was able to choose to do
something wrong we also have that choice
not every Wicked thing we do there's a
devil behind it I think sometimes people
just make those choices and of course
the devil is there and his fallen angels
to tempt us but through the power of
Christ and the spirit you know we can
put out those thoughts we can reject or
resist those thoughts it's not a sin
every time you're tempted with a crazy
thought even Jesus was tempted the Bible
says he was tempted to throw himself
down from the temple of course it was
the devil tempting him but he rejected
that and whenever he was tempted to do
anything wrong he rejected it so we have
that same privilege through the same
power
and you know I think the book they'll be
offering for free called life in the
spirit we'll talk about that how we can
live that Victorious Christian life and
I think as Pastor Doug mentioned it's
important to recognize not every crazy
thought is sin unless we dwell upon it
that's at those times you just push that
out of your mind and say redirect your
thoughts to something wholesome uh if
you'd like to see the book the number to
call again is
800-835-6747 you can answer the book
it's called life in the spirit or dial
pound 250 on your cell phone say Bible
answers live and say life in the spirit
thank you Dan we've got Debbie listening
in Canada Debbie you're on the air
hi Pastor Ross and Pastor Doug how are
you doing great thank you for calling
okay I have a question first of all I
have to say that I'm in the YouTube uh
chat and last week there was a bunch of
us chatting about abortion and there was
somebody in there that doesn't think
she'll ever be forgiven even when she
asks for forgiveness for having an
abortion before she knew Jesus
and I was just wondering if you could
give us some insight on that please yeah
the the Bible is pretty clear that the
only sin that cannot be forgiven is what
you call the unpardonable sin some have
thought well that must be abortion or
infanticide but that's not true God will
even forgive that uh you know because of
the sin of David uh his baby was lost
and Manasseh offered his children they
passed through the fire he was and God
forgave him
and so of course if any any sin that
we're willing to uh repent of and
forsake we will be forgiven the Bible
says all manner of sin and blasphemy
will be forgiven unto men
and so God is extremely merciful and
we're if we're genuinely sorry and we
repent he will forgive and I I pray that
that young lady if she's listening now
will just believe that Jesus is a better
savior than she is a sinner
and he can say to the uttermost the
promises and of course first John
chapter 1 verse 9 says if we confess our
sins he's faithful and just to forgive
us and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness there's no condition
associated with that but that we're
willing to confess and forsake and God
is able to forgive so we take courage
from those promises thank you Debbie
we've got Gary listening in Illinois
Gary welcome to the program
thank you in Luke 22 verse 20 it says
this cup is the New Covenant in my blood
which was shed for you now again
shedding of blood is talked about in
Romans 3 25 whom God set forth as a
propitiation by his blood okay so I
looked up that word and it means gift
offering to remove wrath of God so is
the New Covenant
uh
the removal of wrath of God
no well the word covenant very simply
means agreement
uh every time you buy a house or a car
or even get married it's a covenant and
so the the old Covenant was uh ratified
by the blood it was symbolic it was
ratified by the blood of goats and Lambs
it was the law of God written in this
stone tablets where the people made a
promise he said all the Lord has said we
will do it was an agreement God said
keep these Commandments all bless and
protect you they said all the Lord has
said we'll do that was the agreement it
was ratified with a sacrifice the New
Covenant is the same law
written now in our hearts instead of
stone ratified by the blood of Christ
and so the propitiation the intercession
for our sins is made by the blood of
Jesus but the Covenant itself is the
agreement that God will save us because
of the blood of Christ and he puts a new
heart in us that causes us to walk in
his ways and keep his laws thank you all
right and we you know we've got that uh
great study guide talking about the law
where he talks about it well it's about
Grace and the law and I'm trying to
remember the name of it right now but um
that's God's grace brought out that's it
yes it talks about the covenants right
there that's the one thing that's right
the number to call is
800-835-6747 you can answer the book
it's called does God's grace blot out
the law and we'll send it to you Gary or
anyone listening in the U.S or in Canada
dial pound 250 on your cell phone and
say Bible answers live and ask for it
well get in the mail Judith is listening
right across the border in Nevada Juna
Judith welcome to the program
to both of you my question is about the
Tree of Life as we all know we gonna
uh Worship the Lord of the Sabbath Jesus
every Sabbath is a he says 66
22-23 my focus is the tree of life so we
have bad luck in the tree of life or can
we access the Tree of Life any time we
want to because it's right nearby the
Throne of God so maybe we cannot success
because we need some reverence
around the Throne of God that all the
time that we can access it yes well keep
in mind the the tree of life is going to
be replaced uh the the Garden of Eden
that God planted as near as we can tell
in the same way the New Jerusalem is
coming down from heaven Before the Flood
seems that God caught the garden up
and because that Garden is going to be
in the new Earth Adam had free as far as
we can tell he had free unlimited access
to the tree and that is going to be
restored everything is going to be
restored not uh just the same but even
better so I doubt that God is going to
ration how often you can eat from the
tree
but in the same way in this life you
know you don't want to eat ice cream six
times a day I think people are gonna
have self-control and they're not going
to eat it more than they need to
and of course the Bible tells us that
the fruit of the tree is somewhat unique
a different kind of fruit every month on
the tree of life so you can get your
fill of June's fruit whatever they might
be but then July well there's a
different kind of flavored on the tree
yeah maybe you got your favorite type of
fruit that comes around once a year who
knows but of course yes it's a symbol of
eternal life that we have so absolutely
something special Mark is listening in
Michigan Mark welcome to the program
good evening pastors
um in Joshua 6 it tells the story of
Israel's victory over Jericho we we
recently heard an evangelist say that
the walls came down on the Sabbath it's
challenged to think God scheduled the
actual Slaughter on the Sabbath so is
there any evidence that the seventh day
March began on a Sunday the first day or
on a different day of the week
yeah well we don't know what day it
began but I'm quite certain that God did
not orchestrate the walls of Jericho so
that on the Sabbath day they did the
most work when it talks about they
marched around the city one time for six
days
that means sequence it doesn't mean day
of the week the first day of marching
you know they blew the trumpets and they
marched around the city second day third
day one of those days may have been the
Sabbath
um but he didn't ask them to do anything
other than you know I tease folks and
say they were just taking a nature walk
and special music with the trumpets
that's all that happened so that may
have happened on the Sabbath day but I
think the day that they actually
attacked the city it may have been a
Monday Tuesday Wednesday we don't know
but I doubt it was the Sabbath day
it's uh you know no more than Israel
today would launch a battle on the
Sabbath day and you know one one of the
verse that comes to mind Jesus said
talking about the destruction of
Jerusalem that occurred in 70 A.D Christ
talking to his followers said pray that
your flight be not in Winter and neither
on the Sabbath day well if he's talking
about them fleeing for their life and he
says pray that you don't have to do it
on the Sabbath well it only makes sense
then that the Conquering of Jericho with
all the destruction why wouldn't be on
the Sabbath why would God command that
yeah if he would tell him to pray in
Matthew 24 that's right all right well
thank you Mark appreciate that we have
Liam listening from uh
Ohio Liam welcome to the program
all right thanks for taking my call yeah
my question is regarding John 6 the way
that I read it
um it seems like Jesus is uh claiming
that uh his uh body blood soul and
Divinity are part of the uh Bread and
Wine of communion and I'm really having
a hard time seeing it any other way but
I know that plenty of Christians see it
as just a symbol or uh our Lutheran
friends see it as uh consubstantiation
and I was hoping you could walk me
through the way that you see it now
which verses are you looking at I mean
kind of the whole thing he feeds the 5
000 and the psalm 23 enactment says
unless you eat my flesh and drink my
blood you have no life in you yeah yeah
well now keep in mind at the Last Supper
so the big question and this was a big
debate between Protestants and Catholics
during the Reformation is that uh is the
priest actually converting the emblem of
the the bread and the grape juice into
the literal body and blood of Jesus and
Luther who at one time was a Catholic
priest and Calvin both Catholic priests
they said no it's a symbol and their
argument was when Jesus had the last
supper and he's sitting there with his
disciples and he's all intact
and he points to the bread he says this
is my body and this is my blood
um he wasn't asking them to participate
in some kind of cannibalism because for
one thing that's forbidden in the Bible
uh you know you're not supposed to eat
unclean food or our blood that one of
the first Commandments in the Bible is
do not eat blood
so I think it's it's clearly a symbol of
the sacrifice that Jesus was making and
there's no need for the Lord to actually
biologically transfer make that grape
juice into blood
um you know I think I've been to
communion services and I I used to
attend mass Catholic mass at the
military school and and the bread was
not human flesh it was a wafer and when
the priest drinks the grape juice it's
not blood literal blood so I I think
it's a pretty strong argument that it's
a symbol for the life now you look in
the Old Testament and you've got the
story of Melchizedek who is a type of
Christ and he brings out to Abraham
Bread and Wine
and that that nourished the Army well
Christ is like Melchizedek tells us in
the book of Hebrews and and he nourishes
us with his his life in the gospel
so yeah I think it's a symbol yeah just
add to that a little bit more you know
if you look at the actual passage itself
I think it gives us a clue Jesus said
most assuredly this is verse 53 most
assuredly are saying to you unless you
eat the Flesh of the son of man and
drink his blood you have no life in you
well even the disciples wondered about
this and there were many that were in
the crowd it says that they were
offended and they walked no longer with
him and Jesus turned his disciples and
he said are you also going to forsake me
and they said well Lord where are we
going to go you have the words of life
but then they're respond in verse 60 it
says they said this is a hard saying who
can understand it so even then what they
were puzzled what do you mean Jesus eat
your flesh and drink your blood then
Christ explains this verse 63 he says it
is the spirit that gives life the flesh
profits nothing the words that I speak
unto you they are Spirit in their life
to eat the Flesh and drink the blood of
Christ is to receive his word that's
what Jesus said so he's clearly talking
about symbols and just as we need
physical food to give us physical
strength we need to receive his word and
his Spirit in order for us to have
spiritual strength
yeah and then when Jesus says in
Matthew chapter 12
and I think this still is verse one he
says Beware of the leaven of the
Pharisees and the disciples thought oh
we forgot to bring lunch and she says no
no not literal levenness I'm talking in
spiritual terms this is talking about
the teaching of the Pharisee so Jesus
often spot a spoken symbols and the
disciples thought drink your blood and
eat your flesh and he said no no it's
it's a symbol great question though
thank you Liam we've got Joe listening
in Arizona Joe welcome to the program
hey guys how are you tonight I'm doing
great
all right well I'm going to try to keep
this really simple first off is there an
email that that could be sent because I
have a question but it's kind of a big
question and has lots of parts to it I
don't want to take up all the time on
your show because there's like an email
yeah yeah let me give it to you yeah
it's simple it's just b-a-lquestions at
amazingfacts.org that's b-a-l questions
at amazingfacts.org
all right thank you so so my question is
it
is raised
the same way that you guys uh I guess
preach
but I've I've recently been listening to
somebody
um I found on YouTube in his whole
Ministry is is that we're the angels
from heaven and it's kind of ironic that
uh
uh that you said in your opening about
we're falling because that that's what
he says and so
my question is like there's the the only
problem I'm finding with it is with the
Fallen Angels the the demons that are
talked about in the Bible like when
there was a demoniac and he threw the
the demons out of the body into the pigs
so you have all of these demons running
around so I'm assuming that they had
bodies to begin with and just like
Lucifer goes in and out of you know
people
where are their bodies and and I mean
who are they is it just all the fallen
angels and they can go in anybody's
bodies at any time
yeah well first of all for our friends
listening uh the Bible tells us that you
know sin began with a Lucifer a great
angel of God who rebelled he was cast
out of Heaven he persuaded one-third of
the other angels
uh his former partners you might say to
follow him and they've come to the earth
now the Bible says Angels Are Spiritual
Beings they don't have bodies like we do
Paul said we do not wrestle against
flesh and blood so angels are not flesh
and blood they've got some kind of a
spiritual body it's different and sort
of a mystery for us but uh they you know
they can appear can the Fallen Angels
possess whoever they want no
uh that's the devil's complaint to God
he said you said a hedge about job and
so the Lord limits what the devil can do
to harm us but some people open
themselves up to the devil
and uh you know they can actually get to
the point where they're demon possessed
and that's why Jesus cast out devils and
he sent the disciples forward saying you
can cast them out now on the other
question you mentioned the Bible is
pretty clear People Are Not Angels they
were separate creatures people are not
Fallen Angels think that's what our our
Mormons friends teaches that uh we've
come down to earth and get bodies it's
almost like a form of reincarnation the
Bible doesn't teach that our lives began
when we first became when we're born and
we became conscious of our existence and
our eternity depends on what we do with
the gospel and this life
so um do you want to add anything to
that yeah I thought maybe just the we do
have a study guide called did God create
the devil talks about the fall of
Lucifer the Bible says speaking of the
good Angels they are ministering spirits
and as Dyke said we don't wrestle
against flesh and blood so there is a
dimension of this that we don't fully
understand but they are very real if
you'd like to receive the study guide
called did God create a devil we'll be
happy to say that to anyone who calls
and asks the number for that is
800-835-6747 or just dial pound 250 on
your cell phone say did God create a
devil and that's the name of the study
guide we'll send it to you
Aaron is listening from New York Aaron
you're on the air
hi good evening yeah um multiple places
in the Bible says we must confess our
sins to God because only he can cleanse
us from our sins as he forgives us but
it says in James chapter 5 verse 16 that
we should confess our faults for
trespasses to one another can you tell
me the meaning behind that verse sure
um and if she says part of the reason
for doing that is that we might pray for
one another that we can be healed
um can and if you look in like the new
King James version it doesn't say
confess your sins it says confess your
trespasses
there are different words for sin and
iniquity and uh uh I think that it's
appropriate for believers to share with
their friends you know where I'm
struggling and uh in confidence you can
tell a person you know please pray for
me all right I struggle with gossip or
whatever it isn't you're not required to
do that for forgiveness you just
sometimes will share with friends that
we can trust areas in our lives where we
need prayer and we invite them to
intercede and pray for us
but this is not a an admonition to
confess sin you're not required to
confess into other people you know one
preacher put it this way he said public
sins need to be confessed publicly
private sins you need to confess
privately and then individual if you
send against an individual you need to
go to them first and you need to try and
make things right so you've got to pray
for wisdom you know sometimes things
happen in people's lives and it's not
for everyone else to know about they
need to reconcile with their friend or
work things out and not make a big
public scene of it but there are times
where if people are aware of something
that was done publicly you need to
confess that yep
all right hopefully that helps Erin
thank you we do have a book talking
about forgiveness yeah and I'm trying to
think of the name pass today I think you
wrote the book yeah it's yeah it's a new
uh the gift of forgiveness the gift of
forgiveness yes the number to call for
that is
800-835-6747 and we'll be happy to send
it to anyone who calls and asks just
dial pound 250 and pass it egg you've
got a sermon I always enjoy this one
unforgiveness and I think it's available
70 times seven that's what it's called
70 times seven so anyone wanting to
learn more about that just take a look
at that sermon and you will be blessed
are we going to Aaron in um
I think we were just with Aaron won't be
Christopher in California Christopher
welcome to the program uh hello we have
about a minute and a half before the
break
okay uh my question is would it be a
stand for me to buy from Apple and
Microsoft or any company that supports
abortion and lgbtq rights
all right well that's a great question
um too bad we only have 30 seconds to
answer it but let me just explain it
this way
um you know they're they're
some companies are so big and there are
banks that like when you put your money
in a bank they're probably most major
Banks probably have Investments and
support some of these companies
and you're going to go crazy trying to
buy uh food in a supermarket that
doesn't also sell
alcohol and cigarettes so are you
supporting the alcohol and cigarettes
when you buy your avocados at a certain
Market
at some point you just got to say look
if I don't have peace about it you don't
do it and uh but you know some of these
are big conglomerates and you could
actually say I'm not going to do or buy
anything that's used by Apple
uh or Google and it's going to sort of
eliminate everything
so you know you have to be careful and
wise and how you make those decisions or
you could actually be end up on an
island or in a cave somewhere hey
friends don't go away we're coming back
with more Bible questions in just a
minute and The Best Is Yet To Come tell
your friends to tune in we'll be right
back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
friends Pastor Doug Batchelor this
morning my wife Karen sent me on a
mission she said when you're taping your
announcements this morning tell people
about my favorite amazing facts app it's
called The Amazing Facts radio app you
simply type that in amazing facts radio
you can download the app and you can
listen to good Christian music Bible
reading sermons all day long keep your
faith focused in heaven through the day
check it out if you haven't done it yet
the amazing facts radio app you'll be
blessed
Doug Batchelor was the teenage son of a
millionaire father and show business
mother yet he was living in a cave he
had everything money could buy
everything but happiness but all of the
fun and excitement he enjoyed left his
life out of control his search
eventually led him to a cave above Palm
Springs that became his home while Doug
scavenged for food and garbage bins his
father owned a yacht a Learjet and an
airline but in his cave home he
discovered a dust-covered Bible
as he began to read he soon learned of
his true purpose in life the richest
caveman is the extraordinary true story
of Doug Batchelor that tells how a
rebellious teenager who once lived in a
cave became a tremendous Soul winner for
Jesus Christ it's a thrilling testimony
of the transforming power of God's word
to order your copy of the richest
caveman call
800-538-7275 or visit afbookstore.com
in six days God created the heavens and
the Earth
for thousands of years man has worshiped
God on the seventh day of the week now
each week millions of people worship on
the first day what happened why did God
create a day of rest does it really
matter what day we worship who was
behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit sabbathtruth.com
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7 pm
and 8pm Pacific time to receive any of
the Bible resources mentioned in this
evening's program call
800-835-6747 once again that's
800-835-6747 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to Bible
answers live sometimes called b-a-l and
we're so thankful that you've tuned into
this live International interactive
Bible study and if you've got a Bible
question you can call it in to 800 God
says that's here in North America that's
800-8 uh
463-7297 I've only been sharing that
number for about 25 years you think I'd
have it by now
800-463-7297 we're also streaming live
if you want to see the video it's on uh
amazing facts television that's AF TV
it's on Facebook amazing facts Facebook
Doug Bachelor Facebook and YouTube you
can be watching as well as listening I
don't know why you'd want to because the
answers are all verbal but anyway for
those that are visual you can watch as
well and we want to especially welcome
some of our stations we've got uh
stations around the country special
greeting to our friends listening Paso
Robles on kpr L and also in Sacramento
on kfia one of our Mothership stations
here in California
my name is Doug Batchelor my name is
John Ross and we're going to go back to
the phone lines the next quarter that we
have is Anna listening in Oregon and a
year on the air
evening passers evening so I I don't
have the verses like I usually do but in
the beginning God said that it was good
for
man to not be alone right but then
I think in Matthew uh Jesus says that if
you can keep from it
then
do that
so that's my question
yeah good question
so you know God originally he uh said
when he made man he says not good for
man to be alone now that was just a I
think that's an umbrella truth that God
made man to be a social creature human
is made for relationship and of course
then he made woman because the ultimate
in that relationship is a man and a
woman and a family but I I think it's
good that people aren't alone just even
he wants us to have friends and and be
social have accountability Jesus sent
people out two by two and it was you
know two men so it was important for
them to have a relationship as well but
Paul now Jesus never said it's wrong to
marry Jesus said that in the last days
woe to those that are with child in
nursing during the great time of trouble
and Paul alludes to that there was a
great time of persecution during Paul's
time and he says in those cases it might
be better not to marry do you have that
Pastor Ross yeah you'll find him first
Corinthians chapter 7 verse 6 where
again the context there is this
persecution coming upon the Chris on the
church
um he says for I wish that all men even
were even as myself but each one has his
own gift from God one in this manner and
another in that but I say to the
unmarried and to the widows it is good
for them if they remain even as I am but
if they cannot exercise self-control let
them marry for it is better to marry
than to burn with passion so you know at
a time of severe persecution of course
this wasn't just in the time of Jesus or
you know 70 A.D when Jerusalem was
destroyed and the first century but
there were times of persecution even
during the Dark Ages where it was
difficult to support a family people
were running or moving from place to
place when it came to Mission activity
sometimes it was easier for missionaries
to enter into difficult areas and to go
maybe unmarried but this is not a
general statement right because it's
pretty clear that God created they're
male and female in the beginning and he
performed the first wedding and it is a
type of the relationship that God wants
to have with this church so there's
nothing wrong with marriage yeah of
course Paul he says husbands love your
wives wives your husbands and he talks a
lot about marriage and in the marriage
relationship and he says the marriage
bed is undefiled and so you know Paul
made this one statement and it was
during a time of execution he's also
talking to people who are involved in
itinerate preaching and he said it's a
little easier to get around and preach
the gospel if you don't have a family
and kids so uh does that make sense
hopefully Anna yeah yeah it does but I
mean didn't Jesus say in Matthew that
if you can keep from it then
do that
well Jesus yeah Jesus said some people
are born eunuch some people are made
eunuchs of man but each one has his own
gift uh I don't know that Jesus was ever
advocating that he did warn during the
time of trouble that you know it could
be hard for those that are with children
but I don't think Jesus who have married
you know Peter was married because he
speaks about Jesus performing a miracle
of healing his mother-in-law and there
were woman that traveled with Christ and
the disciples that helped him to provide
so yeah he was not against marriage yep
okay listening in Washington Robert
welcome to the program
hello Pastor Ross Pastor Doug hi Robert
thanks for calling
no problemo
um I have three Bible verses here
um
and they are all sort of contradict each
other
um
I guess you've got a couple of them
Galatians 5 4 where Steve estranged from
Christ by attempting to be justified by
keeping the law
and then there's Romans 3 20 by the
Deeds of the law and no flesh will be
justified
but then there's the uh
the opposite the one 180 uh verse where
it says in Romans 2 13 the the doers of
the law
uh will be will be justified by by
keeping the law
yeah well I don't think there's a
contradiction because the word law and
you have to read the context the word
law could mean one of several things you
have the moral law of the Ten
Commandments and by the way in the Old
Testament God actually makes the
distinction between the different laws
and so Paul writing to these people they
understood when he's talking to the
Galatians
The Ten Commandments are never mentioned
in Galatians it's it's really why since
they've been ever mentioned the big the
particular Commandment that is mentioned
in Galatians is talking about
circumcision
they were believing that they were going
to become righteous through obeying some
of these ceremonial laws you know Paul
would never say it's now okay to kill or
lie or steal or break the ten
commandments so I think most people
that's what you would call a
self-evident truth that God is never
saying it's it's okay to break those
laws now we're not justified by keeping
any law we're all justified by faith but
then when we are saved by faith uh we
want to obey God's law and so that's
what he's talking about there in Romans
chapter 213 that um that there's we're
justified by obedience and
um so I don't know hopefully that made
sense you know the we're judged by our
works
and you read this in Revelation chapter
one we're judged by our works because
our works demonstrate if we've been
saved by faith now that's the key if you
understand that
if you are saved by faith your works and
obedience will be different
so you know Solomon the end of his book
he said here's the whole duty of man
fear God and keep his Commandments for
God will bring every work into judgment
with every secret thing
any thoughts yeah well we got a book
it's called does God's grace blot out
the Lord perfect and it deals with these
very passages the number to call for
that is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the book
does God's grace blot out the law you're
going to suggest dial pound 250 on your
cell phone say Bible answers live and
then ask for the book does God's grace
blot out the law and once again if
you're outside of North America just go
to the website
amazingfacts.org you can read the book
there in the Free Library next Corner
that we have is Lisa in California Lisa
you aren't Bible answers live
hi hi good evening pastors evening
hi um so
so just baptized a Christian
um she's been in the Christian colleges
she was raised a Christian
um to cut the story short last month she
came and told me and my family that she
was a trans man
um so my question is is in the Bible I
know it mentions things that if you
surround yourself with certain types of
people like I think it's Proverbs 13 20
the why is it the wise just surrounding
yourself with wholesome people so that
you won't be influenced so I have four
minor children and they all look up to
her and so my concern and my question is
what if that person is your daughter uh
she's an adult she's in college but I'm
concerned about my little ones because
I've been trying to keep this away from
them it's not a way but try to teach
them how it's not acceptable right how
we love people but it's just not
acceptable but at the same time now it's
in the family so what does the Bible say
when it's your family
yeah that is very difficult and it's
just you know it's sort of indicative of
the cultural we're in right now the the
devil's going after all the young people
and he's getting them all mixed up about
their their gender identity they're
never the scope of the problem was never
like it is now because it's almost being
subsidized uh but what do you do in your
family you know you love your daughter
and you want to show unconditional love
and acceptance but you certainly don't
approve of the lifestyle and how do you
protect the children from an unwholesome
influence or the wrong messaging coming
to them
well that takes the the wisdom of
Solomon and the courage of Elijah I
think that what you have to do is
uh you know
you want your older daughter to feel
that she can come to you and that
there's love there but you probably need
to have a conversation where you say you
know you know we don't approve of this
and we sure don't want that influence on
the kids you know we'd ask that you
respect that and uh you know just
monitor their interaction
if there's no respect for that decision
then you might say you know uh we we
don't want you around the little kids
unless we're around or I don't know
you'd have to have some some boundaries
or something
but that is a tough situation it is it
is a tough and as you say it past it
like it seems like it's becoming an
epidemic in our society it's almost
being promoted it seems like yes social
media and all the rest of it but I think
as a parent you know your first priority
is to try and protect your your children
especially the younger ones and I'll
still be kind to the older ones that
might be making decisions country to us
but setting those those boundaries I
think is important all right thank you
Lisa we've got Sam listening in Arizona
Sam welcome to the program
my question
um is I I know that we're not supposed
to buy or sell on the Sabbath and I'm
wondering if you guys have ever had a
challenge with that I mean I know you
guys travel and such uh
sure well I you know Pastor Ross can
speak for himself but uh and by the way
this is not like a church law it tells
us in the book of Nehemiah that uh the
people were not supposed to be getting
involved in business and buying and
selling on the Sabbath day it was a holy
day it's not a day for doing our work in
our family and most Sabbath Keepers
whether you're Christians or Jews uh you
know if you've got to buy things you do
your shopping you don't do that on
Sabbath that's just sort of uh and
that's why you've even got blue laws in
the country is because the early
Christians realize you're not supposed
to be shopping on Sunday and they
actually Outlaw it now I'm not saying
that that should happen but I'm just
saying that's where those laws came from
they knew that that was not a day for
shopping
so um but in every now and then and
Pastor Ross and we travel
internationally and I'll be taking
another international trip uh next week
um sometimes with a time change and
Airport reports are delayed you find
yourself even in spite of your best
planning things go wrong and all of a
sudden you've you're in some foreign
country and the Sabbath is coming you'll
be caught in emergencies and Jesus said
you know sometimes the ox is in the
ditch
and you do your best to prepare to avoid
that but I think God is a loving and
understanding God and there's a place in
the Bible where Hezekiah he prayed one
time the the priests were trying to keep
up with the demands of the people for
offering sacrifice and as a guy said
they haven't had a chance to cleanse
himself the way they should Lord have
mercy on them and God heard his prayer
and forgave the priests so they could
just keep up with the uh the demand for
sacrifice so I think God is a practical
God but we should do everything we can
to avoid those occasions yeah it's
interesting even back in the time of
Christ the day before the Sabbath our
Friday was referred to as the
preparation day and so they knowing the
Sabbath was coming they would buy what
they have to buy they would cook with
that to cook so that on the Sabbath they
could rest and and so I think even today
we want to do as much of the shopping
and the preparation as possible the day
before the Sabbath so we can rest
however as Pastor Doug says there there
are times where somebody in the family
might get sick and you need to take a
trip to the pharmacy to get some
medicine that's perfectly okay that is
an emergency type of situation but we
want to prepare as much as possible
beforehand yeah and I found one of the
verses it's in Nehemiah chapter 13 verse
17 and Nehemiah says then I contended
with the Nobles of Judah this is when
they were having the people of Tire they
were coming and buying and selling in
the city I contended with them and said
what evil thing is this you do and
you're profaning the Sabbath did not
your fathers do this did not our God
bring all this disaster on this city yet
you bring out a wrath on Israel by
profaning the Sabbath so it was that the
Gates of Jerusalem as it began to be
dark before the Sabbath I commanded the
gates to be shut because all the pagans
were coming in to sell things people
couldn't resist the temptation it was on
sale you know so they understood that
even going way back then
all right thank you next call that we
have is Jim listening in Texas Jim
welcome to the program
thank you gentlemen sure
um my question is pertaining to Jesus
being in the tomb three days and three
nights and I've heard Pastor Doug
explain pushing back into Thursday when
he's he's beginning to when he's
arrested and all but that's still
Thursday Friday Saturday nights I still
don't get where the two days come of the
third day comes in
yeah well it uh that time period
overlaps into three days
so the sufferings of Christ uh you know
sufferings of Jesus began even before he
was arrested in the Garden of Gethsemane
he's you know praying and sweating blood
it's he was in agony before anyone else
laid a hand on him
so and Jesus you know he explained even
in the Last Supper that heaviness
so I I think that you can count Thursday
as part of that so you got Thursday
Friday Saturday he rises Sunday morning
and it's in the Jewish calculation any
part of a day could be considered the
day so if the experience bled over into
a day you could count that day they
didn't count it by the minutes and the
hours
you know we have a book it's cold the
sign of Jonah and it tooks about three
days three nights yep and that'll
explain that even in more detail so to
get that just call
800-835-6747 or you dial pound 250 on
your phone and say Bible answers live
and ask for the book three days three
nights the sign of Jonah and we'll send
that to you next holiday we have is John
listening in Nebraska John welcome to
the program
yeah good evening pastors hi how you
doing
got a question from Revelation verse
chapter two verse 10. okay it stayed in
there of course we're not to fear our
upcoming problems that the devil is
going to put on to us but it says our
trials and tribulations will be 10 days
can you please explain to 10 days
yeah this is the message and Pastor Ross
may want to comment on this as well this
is the message to the Church of Smyrna
this is one of the ages of the church I
think it's the second age of the church
after Ephesus there's a time of great
persecution in Prophecy a day represents
a year and this was a time of severe
persecution I believe under the emperor
Diocletian yeah from the year
303-313 a total of 10 years and this of
course there was persecution throughout
the period of Rome and the Christians
but this tenure period was diocletian's
attempt to completely eradicate
Christianity and of course Christianity
was legalized by constantining 313 so 10
years before that there were a terrible
time of persecution that took place in
Rome and all of the Roman prophecies
throughout Asia Minor yep they not only
burnt Christians they burned Bibles and
he was trying to like you said eliminate
the Christian faith
so it's not talking about 10 days in the
future that message to the Church of
Smyrna is describing 10 days during that
second age of church history
okay thanks so much
Stephen in California Stephen welcome to
the program
she would be in heaven and Jesus said uh
uh for when they arrived they need to
marry or given in marriage
or as the Angels so is there a scripture
that actually says we will be reunited
with our loved ones
well we'll be reunited with saved loved
ones and you could look at first
Thessalonians chapter 4 verse 16. for
the Lord himself will descend from
heaven with a shout where the voice of
the Archangel and the trumpet of God and
the dead in Christ will rise first then
we who are alive and remain shall be
caught up together with them so there
you have it we are together with them in
the clouds to meet the Lord in the air
thus we will always be with the Lord
Comfort one another with these words
he's Paul saying he's actually writing
to the Thessalonians he says you don't
need to sorrow about as others because
you've lost your loved ones you'll be
reunited and the understanding is with
those who've died in faith the dead in
Christ and one more verse First
Corinthians chapter 13 verse 12 Paul
writes for now we see as in America
dimly but then face to face now we know
in part but then I shall know just as I
am no so we're going to know each other
we're going to interact we're going to
be able to worship God we'll see our
loved ones our friends it'll be a day of
reunion when Jesus comes
all right thank you Stephen we do have a
study guide that talks about the second
coming of Christ it's called rescue from
above and we'll be happy to send that to
anyone who calls and asks the number is
800-835-6747 ask for the study guide
rescue from above or dial pound 250 on
your smartphone and ask for that study
guide Dave is listening in Florida Dave
welcome to Bible answers live hey please
what were you doing doing well thank you
and you
I'm quite fine
um I was having a Bible study yesterday
I still move up on Matthew 10 verse 28
where it says that fear Him not which
killed the body
but cannot kill the soul but rather feed
him which can kill that can describe
both by the unsolding head could you
clarify that for me tell them a little
bit a little bit confused on that part
yeah well I think that all of us know
that we've got a physical body and so
the Lord is talking about that there and
a person could have a physical body
without any personality in it uh you
know if a person is brain dead their
body might keep functioning but it's
like the you know lights are on but no
one's home
so you've got your character which is
the combination of your your spirit of
life and the body your personality
uh Jesus said don't be afraid of those
who might torture your body and they
can't really touch your soul soul
meaning the the part of you that will be
your personality in in a new body in
heaven said but fear Him who can destroy
both the body and the soul in the Lake
of Fire
so uh I don't know does that answer what
you're asking
kind of because what I want to get a
clarification because I know the other
person would read this and say use this
to justify to say yes see we have body
and we have a soul which you know what
the world believes in you know when you
die your you know Spirit as they say so
um I just want as I said you know like
when I was doing a study that the spirit
said to me that you know I think the
same thing that you said is speaking
your mind feeling who can kill both body
and mind that's what I get but I just
want to confirm that what I get from
that is actually so forth because I know
persons will read this and make a whole
entire Doctrine from this yeah they've
got the soul as like a separate ghost
that floats around outside your body uh
but the Bible is pretty clear that and
you look at other verses that um the the
soul is the combination of the breath of
life and the body together
and that we don't come back from the
grave we're not conscious and we don't
go off to Heaven until the resurrection
and the Judgment you know Paul said
talking about the resurrection I shall
know even as I am known so that ability
to still recognize who we are to know
who we are to have own thoughts our own
feelings the essence you might say of
life so it's that part sometimes
referred to as the soul and then the
body
whereas Jesus says he can destroy both
body and soul in hell that almost
contradict well that does contradict the
idea that the wicked will have an
eternal burning soul in the Lake of Fire
Jesus says he shall destroy it so there
isn't some part of our being that lives
on independently from the body right
all right thank you Dave we've got Caleb
listening in New York Caleb welcome to
the program
hello Pastor Doug Bassett pass of us
evening how are you guys doing doing
great
so I have a question about Kings when I
know I should be studying prophecy right
now but
prophecy I'm gonna leave I'm gonna let
that you guys teach prophecy because you
guys are missing at it but my question
is from First Kings
um second verse um
third second on first King 2 verse 13 to
25 I think it's um Why did Why did um
what did King Solomon King kill his
brother Indonesia because I started
reading this and I'm confused like
because he asked for a wife Yeah Anna
Niger wanted to have abishag abeshag had
been a concubine you might say of
David's uh adonaija tried to make
himself King
and after David died out of Niger you
know he kept his head down for a little
while but it really bothered him that
his younger brother Solomon was the
youngest it bothered him that his
younger brother he felt like took the
throne and so he began to conspire again
and one of the first things he was going
to do is he thought if I have David's
wife that will show that I have his
throne when when Absalom wanted to
overthrow David as king he took his
concubines
and so Solomon being very wise he saw
what his brother was up to and that it
was going to lead to a rebellion and
when Adam nijah he actually got
Bathsheba to make the request for him
Solomon's mother Bathsheba and he said
now you know can I have uh that
beautiful girl Abhishek his wife after
all you know David never knew her she
was just sort of a hot water bottle to
keep him warm when he was getting old
and
and Solomon saw through what he was up
to and uh he said all right you've
stepped over the line now I'm not going
to have I'm not going to be living in
the shadow of fear that you're going to
try to assassinate me or take over the
kingdom he'd already tried it once so
then Solomon killed out of Niger and he
also killed joab who had conspired
without a Niger to overthrow uh Solomon
so
um he was basically trying to just bring
peace to the kingdom and it did it
brought he had to settle his leadership
and bring peace hey friends we are going
to sign off as you've heard before we
sign off in two stages we're gonna say
farewell to those on satellite but the
rest of you stay close by we're going to
be doing some rapid fire Bible questions
in about 30 seconds
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry locate aided in Granite Bay
California
[Music]
Hello friends and welcome back to Bible
answers live this is the part of the
program where we get to answer some of
your email questions that you've sent if
you'd like to email us your Bible
question just Bal questions at
amazingfacts.org Pastor Doug Daniel is
asking what is your take on reverence in
the sanctuary uh we should do it okay
I could probably say more than that but
you know God is a holy God and in
particular now when we say Sanctuary you
know a lot of churches today they are
using a multi-use facility they may be
meeting in something that serves as a
school during the week or an auditorium
and um but when we set it aside for
religious purposes and we've invited
God's presence I think this should be
reverence there uh the Bible says the
Lord is in his holy Temple at all the
Earth keeps silent and we should uh bow
in reverence before his name so if the
angels are by The Throne of God saying
holy holy holy then God's people when we
come into the presence of God should
show respect okay Warren is asking how
can Satan and his angels still be alive
today if they cannot eat from the Tree
of Life well if if the devil had a
digestive system like a human or like a
physical creature that would be that
would make sense but
the Bible tells us that angels are
spirits and I don't know that the
spirits are sustained by eating you know
bananas or our fruit or that nothing in
the Bible says that the Devils need to
eat
or drink
there's some kind of a they're sustained
in some other way we don't understand
it's something of a mystery in that
world but yeah so I don't think that
he's needed to eat from the Tree of Life
all right then we have Kathy that's
asking where in the Bible does it say
that children who die before the age of
accountability will be saved if their
parents are saved well that is that's a
difficult uh subject because you know on
one hand you're asking
uh every child that's ever lived that
dies before the age of accountability
are they all in heaven and there's some
question with that but then
um certainly I don't believe children
that die before the age of
accountability are going to be suffering
in hell
but then Paul says something I think
it's First Corinthians chapter seven
where he basically says that the the
children of the believing parent are
sanctified
by their parents faith and so the the
believing appearance it has some
sanctifying influence and many times in
the Bible when a person was saved it
says they and their house meaning maybe
their family their children hey friends
I hope that helps a little bit we are so
thankful that you've joined us for Bible
answers live we are a faith-based
Ministry meaning we're brought to you by
you if you've been blessed keep us on
the air we'll study next week
[Music]
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]